you've said in the past and I have to
ask this because I heard that this could
be and this is it's not a spoiler
question for endgame but it's I heard
this could be the first Marvel movie
that you guys are releasing in three
hours and you've said that before are
you still at the three hour mark is it
close to that we're we're still three
hour mark right do you think it's a day
the studio is gonna be down with three I
mean I think the studio is down with
whatever the best story is and and right
now the we you know we think the movies
playing well and and we've had you know
great responses from our test audiences
and we're feeling very good about where
it is we're still doing work to it yeah
we're not done with it but it is you
know again this is a culmination film
you know 22 movies it's a lot of
storytelling to work into it and you
know emotion is an intrinsic part of
that to us and when you want when you
have to tell a really complicated story
and you want strong emotional moments
for the characters it just requires a
certain amount of real estate and this
one in particular is feels like three
hours worth of real estate I would be
down with the four-hour movie my only
thing is for kids like if you're even
thinking intermission or no joke about
it the Edit room but I think you've
screened the movie four times for
audiences we've screened the movie four
times for audiences now so there are
people out there that know how it ends
perhaps perhaps but and that for the
first three screenings not a single
person got up to go to the bathroom no
more I could ask you a million other
questions I'm just gonna say and I mean
it's seriously amazing work on infinity
war III give hats off the visual effects
are insane
thank you so much for your time
you